where are you from it's called oh I Spit
and for the town is Huddersfield yes and
the village is called skelemans Thorpe
skalman Thor yes but now there's a
special name for people from Skeletor
which I don't understand I'm allowed to
say this out because this goes out past
when kids have gone to bed yeah it goes
out tomorrow
so um the name for me would be
affectionately referred to as are you a
shot glass yeah and this shot sax a chat
beats us this shot everything the
village Scanlan pops really long and but
then it's it's to do with I really don't
remember
and the specifics but hopefully you know
this is the vague story but I think in
the olden days there was a quarry and
the local trade was people smashing
slate and so they were shatters and so
then you were if you from the village
and the workers lived in the village you
were a shatter and then now however many
years later you're from Shack I didn't
really realize it and my boyfriend the
time now husband Jews from Tucson could
go out a way key transition and shacks
just opening oh my god welcome to the
family
the Shatt family Tucson Arizona yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]